METE ATAMEL: Let's see
how to build and launch
an ASP.NET core app
from Google Cloud Shell.
First, start Cloud Shell
from Google Cloud console.
By default, Cloud Shell has
.NET command line tool already
installed.
Let's create a folder for our
app and use .NET new -t web
command to create a new web app.
This creates a number
of files for our webapp.
Let's open the Orion, Cloud
Shell's browser-based editor,
and edit program.cs file,
and add UseUrls line
to make sure that the
webapp binds to port 8080.
Save, and now run .NET
restore to download the new
dependencies for our app.
Finally, execute .NET run
command to compile and run
our application.
Now do a web preview, and
your ASP.NET core app now
runs on Linux in the cloud.